listening to a film career
and Terry warning
I talk radio
but as the first time director things
wouldn't cut you know performances
wouldn't cut together sometimes it was
my direction sometimes it was the actors
body movements and but all of those
things kind of conspired to just um you
know make me one I wanted to quit every
single day there wasn't a day that went
by that I thought were done no one
really knew needs to know this film ever
was conceived no one's waiting for word
no one cares so I could quit right now
and I think I will really it was a
tremendous surprise when we didn't win
two awards which but it really I mean at
that point when it went to the group it
really you know everyone brings
something to the party everyone makes
the film what it is so when I'm pitching
for stuff I'm I know that I'm pitching
against sometimes thousands of people in
fact last week I was told there's some
new human contact which is in Canada she
runs a production company up there and
somebody put an advert a pot arm for a
piece of music for an ad TV ad and four
thousand composers responded within five
days so it's a highly competitive
environment at the moment and it's very
accessible as well with with the
internet and we're speaking across the
the world right now and there it's
almost seamless